do you eat good on the road you'll learn
this little tricks of the trade roll the
video please this is how Mook pull up in
a way that's how I eat man you know what
I'm saying I order Grocery and then I
cook my food and so here we got the
burners you know and then we got all the
utensils the spray the oil you know when
I make breakfast I got jelly in there
you know what I'm saying the knife
peanut butter
um so when I'm hungry at night I can
make me a little PB and J I try try and
eat really good man cause you know I got
10 more years in this thing so I'm gonna
be 40. I gotta make sure I still can
move around and do this whenever you
ready you know I'm a patented travel
kitchen travel kitchen thought